sciences bonjour et bienvenue pour cette
option sous nous allons tenter de
répondre à la question comment devenir
immortel immortel rien que ça mais c'est
qu'on se mouche pas du coude
vivre c'est respirer s'exposer au soleil
et aux agressions du monde qui provoque
irrémédiablement l'accumulation de
mutation et l'oxydation de votre
machinerie cellulaire
la formation de radicaux libres qui
abîment votre adn et le raccourcissement
des télomères de vaud chromosomes même
la joconde subi les outrages du temps
mais ça c'est la réponse à comment
vieillir ton et fille vont pas mourir
mais la vraie grande question c'est le
pourquoi
car pour comprendre comment devenir
immortel il faut comprendre pourquoi on
meurt
quelles sont les raisons évolutif
profondes qui ont conduit les espèces à
ne pas être immortel et il y a un vrai
paradoxe derrière tout cela car en
théorie plus un individu vit longtemps
plus il aura l'occasion de se reproduire
par conséquent il aura plus de
descendants et donc ces jeunes se
répandront répandant avec eux la
longévité
ainsi la durée des vilains sa ligne et
devrait continuer de s'accroître de
génération en génération jusqu'à
atteindre l'immortalité
à première vue et d'un point de vue
strictement darwinia cela n'a pas de
sens de mourir puisque cela limite nos
capacités à nous reproduire et aux yeux
de la sélection naturelle la
reproduction
c'est ce qui importe le plus et cela est
d'autant plus bizarre que ce ne serait
techniquement pas impossible de vivre
beaucoup plus longtemps
en effet nous disposons naturellement de
tout un tas de systèmes de réparation de
l'adn de suppression des radicaux libres
et même de rallongement des télomères
alors pourquoi donc par année c'est le
baron samedi tous ces systèmes
cesse-t-il de fonctionner au bout d'un
moment donné si notre corps peut se
réparer tout seul et les mutations être
corrigé alors pourquoi finit-il par nous
abandonner pourquoi meurt-on pourquoi
tous les organismes vieillissent et
meurent
on pourrait penser que les méduses les
coraux ou bien les plantes qui se
reproduisent par bouturage et les autres
organismes qui se reproduisent par
clonage sont au moins théoriquement
immortel et oui comme l'individu fille
est génétiquement un différenciables de
l'individu mer alors si rennes et
demeure comment être sûr que c'était
l'individu mer mais même là il est
encore possible de différencier
l'individu mère de l'individu fille
grâce à des marqueurs chimiques ou grâce
au partage inique
des dommages cellulaires et donc de voir
lequel des deux est le plus vieux et la
conclusion est que même les organismes
qui se clone ne sont pas exemple de
vieillissement
il ne s'agit que d'une immortalité
théorique une méduse nommé turritopsis
nutricula saurait faire rajeunir ses
cellules sous l'effet d'un stress mais
cette espèce est encore trop peu connue
pour qu'on en soit sur disons qu'en
principe elle a tout ce qu'il faut pour
être réellement immortel donc jusqu'à
preuve du contraire tous les êtres
vivants vieillissent et meurent mais que
gagne-t-on donc à vivre tu es se laisser
mourir comme ça
une première réponse serait tout
bêtement eux pour laisser la place aux
jeunes
prenons le cas théoriques d'une espèce
dont les individus sont immortels ces
individus se multiplieraient rapidement
et donneraient naissance et des petits
tout aussi mortelle qui finirait par
peuple et le monde et épuise rapidement
leurs ressources
les premières générations ne quittant
pas la scène après l'entrée de leur
progéniture le théâtre de la vie
finirait rapidement par être saturé cela
peut sembler simpliste mais si vous
vivez trop longtemps vous consommez les
ressources des générations suivantes ce
qui du coup amenuise leurs chances de
reproduction à perm c'est tout votre
espèce qui risque d'être condamné alors
si les mortalités semble être une bonne
chose pour l'individu et ses chances de
reproduction
elle savait en fait ne pas être
bénéfique sur le long terme une
observation intéressante de ce point de
vue mais encore difficile à interpréter
a été fait de nombreuses fois sur des
souris de laboratoire en leur
fournissant que le strict minimum 1
nourriture ces souris ont vécu lipad
seulement près de 30% plus longtemps que
des souris bien nourri le corps
comprendre est il d'une façon ou d'une
autre que ces souris n'était plus une
menace pour les ressources des
générations futures
plus troublant encore et que chez les
invertébrés le vieillissement est
contrôlé par une protéine proche de
l'insuline des vertébrés
or chez les vertébrés l'insuline
responsable du contrôle du taux de sucre
dans le sang
y aurait-il un lien l'insuline fait
vieillir et mangez moi fait vivre plus
longtemps alors mangez moi serait t'il
le secret de l'immortalité
après tout les animaux ectothermes
mangent moins que les ans nos terres
mais vivent souvent beaucoup plus
longtemps donc le son numéro à la clé de
la longévité assuré c'est un régime
draconien la la la la on s'enflamme pas
s'il vous plaît c'est l'air d'avoir un
avis contrastés l'appel avis contrastés
en effet le lien entre le nombre de
calories ingérées et la longévité est
loin d'être élucidé il tâcherait donc
moyen de ne pas se laisser emporter
n'est ce pas et pour ce qui est de
l'insuline chez l'homme elle n'a aucun
effet sur la longévité
oui s'il suffisait de se passer
d'insuline pour vivre longtemps alors le
diamètre ne serait plus un problème donc
faire de la place aux jeunes pourquoi
pas mais faudrait pas non plus commencer
à dire n'importe quoi
si cette hypothèse est vrai alors il ya
des choses qu'on s'attend à trouver dans
la nature comme des organismes à
obsolescence programmée les êtres
vivants avec une sorte de système
d'autodestruction si cela était vrai
alors il existerait des gènes de la mort
ça pourrait être le cas chez au moins
certaines espèces
nombreuses sont les espèces dont la vie
s'arrête abruptement juste après la
reproduction comme si elles étaient
munies d'un système d'autodestruction
c'est le cas des pieuvres du bambou et
des saumons qui meurt en pleine force de
l'âge juste après s'être reproduit mais
faire de la place aux jeunes générations
ne serait pas la seule raison de ce
suicide programmé à l'époque de la crise
permien trias la plus terrible crise
d'extinction de masse que notre planète
est connu et qui eut lieu il ya 250
millions d'années une famille nommé
l'été rapide ancêtres des mammifères a
survécu grâce à une stratégie originale
les paléontologues ont démontré grâce au
strict de croissance des os que les
individus de ces espèces vivent et des
vies très courte et se reproduisent et
très jeune cela permet d'avoir un temps
entre les générations très courts et une
plus grande probabilité de voir des
innovations évolutive apparaître d'une
génération à l'autre ainsi livre vite et
mourir jeunes augmente les capacités
d'adaptation d'une espèce dans un
environnement très perturbé comme celui
qui sévit c'est la crise permien trias
des individus vivent longtemps et se
reproduisant à intervalles plus large
n'aurait pas eu le potentiel de
s'adapter se reproduire et mourir vite
s'est accéléré la vitesse de l'évolution
vous rendez vous compte 100
l'obsolescence programmée d'été rapide
les mammifères que nous sommes ne serait
peut-être jamais apparue la mort
conférerait donc d avantage évolutif non
négligeable par l'individu immédiatement
mais à sa progéniture en lui économisant
des ressources et en accroissant les
chances d'innovation évolutive oui oui
c'est un début d'explication qui marche
pour les cas extrêmes qu'on a cité mai
il ya bien plus que ça des cas où la
mort n'est pas une adaptation mais n'est
pas non plus un fardeau
reprenons un exemple théorique simple
imaginons une souris morte elle laisse
aux immortels comme les souris normales
ont des ennemis naturels chat et renard
qui les manches maladie qui les
terrasses chaussures et pneus qui les
écrase
ah si cette souris tout immortel soit
elle n'est pas invulnérable ni
indestructible ce qui fait que sur un
temps suffisamment long son espérance de
vie finit par tomber
inévitablement à zéro sa probabilité de
mourir d'une mort accidentelle devient
inévitable autrement dit à quoi bon être
immortel quand on est une souris alors
qu'on n'a aucune chance de dépasser
l'âge de 5 ans sans se faire bouffer
écrasé ou contaminé par une maladie
mortelle
autant tout misé sur la reproduction et
quitter la scène avec honneur et surtout
une descendance dans la nature connaître
la vieille assez rare même quand on en
est théoriquement capable
le pinson des arbres que vivre jusqu'à
près de 30 ans en captivité alors que
cette durée de vie moyenne à l'état
sauvage et de moins de deux ans plus
proche de nous les chimpanzés peuvent
vivre jusqu'à 50 ans en captivité
mais à peine 50% des passes l'âge de 8
ans à l'état sauvage pour l'homme c'est
un peu pareil
les sources historiques montrent qu
avant les progrès de la médecine moderne
atteindre l'âge de 30 ans et c'était
déjà pas mal les espèces qui survivent
le plus longtemps à l'état sauvage sont
aussi celles qui échappent le mieux aux
prédateurs comme le rates obtenu qui
vivent bien cachés sous terre les
espèces les plus grosses sont aussi
celles qui craignent le moins des
prédateurs et vivent le plus longtemps
éléphant baleines requins du groenland
et surtout les arbres dont beaucoup
peuvent être pluri centenaire ils sont
virtuellement indestructible voilà donc
une première raisons pragmatiques pour
laquelle on meurt non seulement vivre
éternellement peut être préjudiciable à
votre descendance mais en plus cela ne
sert à rien puisque vos probabilités de
mourir précocement restiez même repenser
aux poulpes et au saumon si vos chances
d'arriver à l'âge de la reproduction
sont déjà de seulement 10% alors celle
d'arriver à survivre jusqu'à la saison
de reproduction suivantes sont encore
plus infimes
dès lors à quoi bon essayer de survivre
plus longtemps que cela apparemment pour
eux ça ne vaut pas le coup à cela il
faut ajouter un autre facteur qui
rentrent en jeu celui du coût de la vie
le vivant se décomposent naturellement
laissé un corps sans vie à l'abandon il
disparaîtra en quelques semaines pour
que ce corps reste frais et disponible
il faut l'entretenir
maintenir le soigne et renouveler ses
pièces et tout cela coûte cher en
énergie pour vivre éternellement il vaut
donc mieux ne pas être radin votre corps
est comme une grande usine chimique dans
laquelle des milliers de réactions au
lieu certaines produisent des déchets
non désirables l'intérieur votre santé
et qu'il faut dépolluer pour dépolluer
une usine
il est très facile et peu coûteux de
nettoyer la surface au jet d'eau il est
par contre beaucoup plus difficile et
fastidieux d'enlever chaque petits
débris incrustée dans le sol est encore
plus difficile et coûteux de dépolluer
le sol sous le site
votre corps c'est la même chose il est
très facile et peu coûteux de vous
maintenir en vie de vous entretenir et
de vous réparez vite fait mal fait pour
vous amener à l'âge de la reproduction
dans un état disons correct par contre
il est tellement coûteux de dépolluer
chaque petite molécule de déchets que
votre corps préfère les laisser
s'accumuler provoquant ainsi au bout
d'un certain temps maladie et
vieillissement les petits et les gros
bobos s'accumulent les mutations après
un coup de soleil par exemple sont
réparées à la va-vite juste ce qu'il
faut pour que vous soyez présentable
pour votre premier rencard car il faut
pas oublier que c'est ça le plus
important
que vous soyez vivant et en bonne santé
à l'âge de la reproduction ce qui se
passe après le vieillissement et des
maladies n'a pas d'effet sur la
transmission de votre patrimoine
génétique à vos descendants et n'a que
peu d'importance
ainsi comparé à quelqu'un qui aurait abc
beaucoup d'énergie dans un corps parfait
qui a coûté extrêmement cher pour être
retapé à neuf
votre corps un peu pété mais pas trop
lui à économiser de l'énergie pour la
reproduction pour gagner une bataille
contre un rival sexuelle par exemple ou
pour parader devant votre promise toute
la nuit
le revers de la médaille c'est que votre
corps cela excuse et se fatigue et puis
mourir mais qu important que leur
production elle reste un succès
l'important c'est que vos spermatozoïdes
et vos bulles soit au top le corps lui
n'est qu'un moyen de transport pour eux
un objet d'apparat du consommable que
vos gènes ont appris à considérer comme
jetables une fois qu'il s'était transmis
à la génération suivante les gènes de
nos cellules reproductrices non pas
l'intérêt à garder notre corps en vie
plus que nécessaire une fois nos gènes
passé à nos descendants
nous devenons superflu dommage qu'on
doive mourir mais c'est notre lot à tous
car la vie n'est plus nécessaire
l'important c'est de bien comprendre
qu'une fois la reproduction passé la
survie est inutile loin mais là je sais
ce que vous vous dites nous autres
humains nous ne mourrons pas juste après
nous être reproduit pas plus qu'eux
chats ou les chiens certes cela vient
entre autres du fait que nous sommes des
mammifères et que nous les mammifères
sommes très doué en soins parentaux
or pour pratiquer les soins parentaux
vaut mieux survivre à sa reproduction
pour l'espèce humaine la sélection
naturelle a même favorisé le soin de la
progéniture par les grands-parents
augmentant encore un peu plus notre
espérance de vie donc le son numéro deux
pour devenir immortel il faut se rendre
indispensable y compris quand on
vieillit le secret de la longévité
humaine vient certainement de là sinon
pour vous rendre utile le plus longtemps
possible vous pouvez toujours faire
comme les rênes fourmies et et pondre
des petits en continu pendant 30 ans
d'affilée et point de vue de la
sélection naturelle ça marche aussi
elle s'est un peu plus contraignant de
point de vue anatomique vous l'aurez
donc compris mort et reproductions sont
indissociablement liés aux yeux de la
sélection naturelle si vous me permettez
une petite personnification une fois la
reproduction passer votre survie importe
peu en fait elles mêmes non désirables
la pression de sélection pour un
maintien en bonne santé de votre corps
après la reproduction devient donc moins
forte
c'est alors que c'est juste une fois
encore un nouvel effet plus pervers un
phénomène qui va accentuer encore plus
le vieillissement puisque une fois la
reproduction passait plus rien ou si peu
n'a d'importance aux yeux de la
sélection naturelle
alors elle laisse l'opportunité à des
mutations délétère de s'accumuler
si celle ci ne s'exprime qu'après la
reproduction
reprenons notre souris théorique voici
son espérance de vie
voici l'âge auquel elle se reproduit à
partir de là ces jeunes se sont transmis
les bons comme les mauvais évidemment
les mauvais gènes ne peuvent pas être
des gènes qui s'exprime avant la
reproduction
sinon notre souris est morte par contre
si c'est mauvais gènes s'exprime après
la reproduction alors si trop tard ils
ont été transmis à la descendance c'est
mauvais gènes vont s'exprimer et
génération après génération s'accumuler
et finir par faire vieillir et mourir
vos petites souris et la sélection
naturelle n'y pourra rien les mutations
ayant lieu après la période de
reproduction vont se transmettre à la
progéniture
et ce même si elles sont délétères car
elles s'expriment trop tard pour que la
sélection naturelle puisse agir dessus
de telles mutations s'accumulent
inévitablement raccourcissant toujours
un peu plus l'espérance de vie
les souris vivent de moins en moins
longtemps l'âge de leur mort se
rapprochant de l'âge de leur
reproduction par l'accumulation de ces
mutations
tout se passe comme si une espérance de
vie limite se mettait en place chez
l'homme détiennent maladie s'exprimant
tard dans la vie sont légion parmi les
plus connus citons les innombrables
cancer alzheimer parkinson la chorée de
huntington
il c'est sans compter un nombre
incalculable de dégénérescence physiques
liées à l'âge mal de dos cataractes
chute des dents des cheveux etc
tous sont autant de désordre qui ne
s'exprime que tard dans la vie à la
proche ou à partir des 40 ans et sont
donc déjà transmis à nos enfants en ne
reproduisant avant 40 ans nous empêchons
la sélection naturelle d'éliminer ces
maladies leçon numéro 3 dongkuk pour
vivre vieux reproduisait boutard ça
marchera peut-être dans dix ou quinze
génération effet garanti cela a été
prouvé chez les mouche du vinaigre et
les vers nématodes qu'on a empêché de se
reproduire en les obligeant à copuler
tard dans leur vie l'espérance de vie de
leurs descendants étaient des x ça aussi
fait baisser la fertilité des mouches il
semblerait que longévité et fertilité ne
fasse pas bon ménage ce qui est plutôt
logique
mais bon faut savoir ce qu'on veut à la
fin alors qu'une maladie comme la
progéria qui a fait que les enfants dès
la naissance n'a pas l'occasion d'être
transmises et de se répandre dans le
patrimoine génétique de notre espèce les
dégénérescences fille est à l'ag des
maladies citées plus haut sont quant à
elles un héritage de très longue date
que nous devons au fait que nos ancêtres
ne dépassait que rarement l'âge de 30
ans selon la même logique mais en la
poussant un poil plus loin alors rien
n'empêcherait karjen ayant des effets
très positifs sur la reproduction puisse
provoquer ensuite des dégâts
irréparables entraînant finalement le
vieillissement et la mort comme un effet
secondaire oui c'est tout à fait juste à
choisir entre longévité et reproductions
la sélection naturelle optera toujours
pour la reproduction
alors non rien n'empêche en théorie un
gène de favoriser le premier au
détriment du second un tel gène sera
même plus que bienvenu en réalité ils
augmentent les succès reproductif très
bien on prend et six as aux dépens de la
longévité m a tant pis et cela
expliquerait très bien pour que les
mouches qui vivent le plus longtemps
sont aussi celles qui se reproduisent le
moins connaissez vous la petite histoire
de la chandelle qui voulait briller en
société
pour se faire remarquer la chandelle
bria deux fois plus fort mais alors
qu'elle avait brillé on ne peut plus
brillamment elle s'éteignit deux fois
plus tôt que les autres
tant pis pour la chandelle ou tant mieux
car au final qui connaît l'histoire des
chandelles banal personne seule
l'histoire de la plus brillante des
chandelles
perdurer bon allez métaphore c'est bien
mais prenons maintenant des exemples
simples et concrets pour illustrer le
principe les hormones sexuelles que nous
ccre et on augmente la libido et rendre
nos caractères sexuels secondaires plus
attrayant seins et fesses pour les
femmes musculature pour les hommes et la
crinière si vous êtes un lion en en
sécrétant plus encore et toujours plus
vous augmenterez votre sex-appeal et
donc vos chances de reproduction du tout
bénef pour la sélection naturelle
petit problème cette sollicitation
accroît aussi notablement vos chances de
cancer au niveau des organes sexuels
mais ça à la sélection naturelle s'en
cogne puisque quand ça arrivera il sera
déjà trop tard bo gen d'ultra séducteur
seront transmis à votre progéniture qui
elle aussi aura un succès notable auprès
du sexe opposé
puis le cancer oui mais encore une fois
trop tard pour être contre sélectionné
c'est cadeau empoisonné dans la même
lignée saviez vous que ce sont les mêmes
hormones qui vous rendre fertile
mesdames qui provoque ensuite
l'ostéoporose la médaille et son revers
on continue et le mécanisme qui favorise
l'arthrose saviez vous qu'il est lié à
celui qui favorisent la croissance que
nous sommes jeunes achètent un avantage
et qui en paiera le prix tant que
l'addition se paye
après la reproduction bien sûr vous
rappelez vous quand on a dit que chez la
mouche augmenter l'espérance de vie
faisait aussi baisser la fertilité et
bien figurer pour que chez le ver
nématode l'appelation de la lignée
germinale provoque carrément une
augmentation de l'espérance de vie de 60
%
moralité leçon numéro trois pour devenir
immortel séparez vous de vos deux enfin
coupé voulait enfin vous voyez de quoi
je parle quoi on parle beaucoup en bas
ou coupent le vieillissement et la mort
serait donc aussi des effets secondaires
regrettable de notre grande fertilité et
cet effet secondaire nous en subissons
les conséquences nettement visible au
coup de vieux que nous prenons après une
grossesse et un accouchement
un merci la sélection naturelle pas
moyen de s'en débarrasser puisque de son
point de vue ça y est nos jeunes sont
transmis alors le reste bas on s'en tape
mais dis toi que ça pourrait être pire
je vois pas comment pensent donc aux
mâles de la souris marsupial c'est un
exemple extrême d'effets secondaires au
lieu de vivre normalement le mâle
consacre 100 % de son énergie à la
reproduction lors de la saison des
amours et résultat plus de nourriture
juste
du sexe du 5 ce jusqu'à l'épuisement du
sexe ce jour et nuit jusqu'à en mourir
du point de vue personnel on est
d'accord c'est plutôt un gros échec bien
épique mais du point de vue darwinia
c'est très efficace descendante
abondante assuré et transmission des
gènes à foison transmission d'une bonne
malédiction aussi c'est certain mais
qu'importe puisque la descendance est
abondante
c'est en somme à darwin awards l'inversé
les hommes sont quand même pas trop à
plaindre
certaines femelles araignée offre
littéralement leur corps en pâture à
leur progéniture
c'est pas enviable 1 en conclusion
pourquoi meurt-on et bien tout
simplement parce que d'une part
évolutive m'en parle en l'immortalité
serait inutile et que d'autre part elle
serait plutôt encombrante voire même
délétère une population dix mortels sur
peupleraie le monde jusqu'à son
extinction
de plus un individu immortels ne peut
pas s'adapter aux variations de son
environnement
par contre les individus d'une espèce
produisant des générations successives
eux le peuvent
enfin la sélection naturelle devient
aveugle après la reproduction l'essence
a cumulé les mutations délétère ou pire
permettant l'existence de mutation
mortels tant qu'elles favorisent la
reproduction
merci la sélection naturelle la mort est
donc un pur produit de l'évolution
darwinienne un enfant de la sélection
naturelle
loin d'être un paradoxe le phénomène
demain on n'a aucun sens autrement qu'à
la lumière de l'évolution des espèces
dans un monde parfait la mort
n'existerait pas donc la prochaine fois
quand vous demandera pourquoi vous
voulez pas d'enfant vous pourrez
répondre que c'est parce que vous
travaillez à rendre la vue et la
sélection naturelle pour le salut
l'immortalité de notre espèce les gènes
de la sénescence sont présents chez tous
les animaux ce qui ferait remonter ce
phénomène à au moins 800 millions
d'années voire un milliard d'années
imaginez-vous avant cette époque avant
tout cela quand le monde n'était
peut-être peuplée que d'être immortel
web à des bactéries et des algues
unicellulaires ça fait pas rêver non
plus un rêve et se plaît
évidemment la théorie évolutif de la
sénescence et de la mort est encore
bougrement incomplète si cette vidéo
vous a fait vous posez plus de questions
qu'elle n'a apporté de réponse c'est
tout à fait normal qui en réalité ne
savons encore que peu de choses de
l'évolution de la mort c'est une
discipline en plein boom la mort a de
l'avenir
elle illustre à quel point vie évolution
et morts sont liées par exemple on a
découvert récemment que des êtres
unicellulaires pratiquer la mort
cellulaire programmée le suicide à
l'échelle d'une seule cellule en quelque
sorte dans un organisme entier cela ne
pose pas de problème car la mort
cellulaire permet par exemple de
détruire les cellules entre les doigts
de l'embryon de telle sorte que vous
n'ayez pas les mains palmer elle empêche
aussi la prolifération des cellules et
donc les cancers
mais quel avantage aurait une cellule
unique à posséder un programme de
suicide si son activation ne bénéficie
pas à tout un organisme entier pourquoi
un unicellulaires c'est suiciderait pour
le bien de qui est pourtant des
organismes unicellulaires ont été
observées en train de pratiquer le
suicide des zags lors des marées rouges
par exemple agissant ainsi à l'unisson
comme un organisme unique et pas comme
un ensemble d'organismes indépendants
certaines algues en période de carence
se suicide pour que leurs petites
copines puisse survivre c'est comme
saborder le navire pour sauver toute la
flotte
et ce comportement témoigner d'une
coordination des actions entre ces
unicellulaires d'un lien non physique
donc probablement chimique qui les unit
c'est comme ça pense-t-on que la vie
aurait commencé à devenir
multicellulaires d'abord en collaborant
à distance puis de façon rapprochée au
sein d'un organisme
la mort n'est donc pas que la fin de la
vie c'est aussi un révélateur de nos
origines biologiques la mort c'est la
multi cellular it et la mort c'est la
reproduction
bref la mort c'est la vie
[Musique]